Neal is in Atlanta Georgia I Neal how
are you last beyond measure Dave how are
you doing sir
better than I deserve what's up yes I
just had a quick question wanted to get
consistent by from you on asking for a
raise but I've only been in a job for
six months and fresh out of college for
just over at you okay well a good way to
think about any negotiation is the first
thing you do switch moccasins so let's
pretend you owned a company and you had
a guy who's six months out of college
working for you under what conditions
what what there would be three or four
things that pop to mind immediately but
what let's see what you think under what
conditions would you give him a raise uh
I mean in my mind it would have to be
you know productivity you know if
they're actually accomplishing the goals
that the company said at least for the
department specific type of thing you
know if he coming in early family the
really just kind of goal oriented and
working hard really a couple other
things that come to mind is a you'd have
to be making enough profit to be able to
give the raise right true if you own the
company so I really doesn't matter how
great the employee is if you're broke it
doesn't matter about giving them raises
so that that would be in consideration
and you kind of got to think about that
in the in the environment you probably
have a feel how the company is doing you
may not know details but I know pretty
good details of it actually okay it's a
science field and so what we're doing in
a very specific test that there's all my
three labs in the country that do the
test and it's a it's pretty complicated
so basically overall we are the
department in the whole company a
company that tolls about a two and a
half million dollar profit every year
we're the department that puts the
company in the black and I'm one of two
employees that is considered high
complexity which basically means we have
a four year degree which qualifies us to
actually do the antibody rinses and such
so the second thing is after I know I'm
making a profit is I'm not going to pay
you a whole lot more then I can replace
you for less this early in your tenure
and so what can I go hire your
replacement for and so if your
replacement is X and you're asking for
2x you're dreaming right does that make
sense
now some want somebody's but the longer
someone's been with you the harder it is
to replace them because they not only
have the knowledge and the skills but
they also have the the cultural aspects
of the experience of with the company
and they know what to do in certain
situations so someone who works for our
team has been with us five years in one
position is more valuable than someone
in the same position that is doing the
similar work level that that's only been
here for six months because that five
years experience does make them able to
see things do things and know things for
productivity wise so that's something to
think about as well so based on all of
that normally most things would say
unless you've agreed to something
different on the front end
most people review compensation once a
year and you're coming in after just six
months am i understanding that right yes
sir
okay and so how do you explain that to
me if I'm your leader well what I plan
is because apparently we're having
performance reviews coming up at the end
of the month oh good
so that that's an encouraging thing
we've been told but it's going to be
basically like a compensation it Ray's
based on performance I'm are hoping and
expecting it so the conversation is is
the table set for the conversation good
we're not having to come in and put the
knives and forks on the table they're
already there good Eve that that's all I
just I just didn't know exactly how to
you know gear the cover it's a stylist
and it's part of but it changes the
conversation that's why I was alright so
because it's already set so I would just
do this then again putting on the shoes
of the guy in the other seat what do you
want to hear well I'll tell you as an
employer I like hearing that folks are
grateful for what they already have Dave
I really love working here and I really
want you to know I'm grateful and I'm
grateful for the pay it's I this is a
dream job for me and I know we're
sitting you're talking about performance
reviews and that kind of stuff so this
is me role playing
with you okay so uh you know since we're
sitting here talking about that I see
that this area is doing really really
well and and certainly I'd like to do as
well as I can do financially and I want
to know that I'm adding value to the
company and I think I'm adding value to
the company and if I am how can we talk
about that showing up in my paycheck in
a reasonable way and I don't want you to
hear me asking this out of lack of
gratitude because I'm grateful but I
want to bring it I want to help you win
the Super Bowl and I want to get paid
like the quarterback of a team that's
wins the Super Bowl and so show me how
to how to be so valuable to you that you
write me a nice check and smile while
you're doing it how can I help you win
like that and guys that are leading gals
that are leading love hearing a young
guy say that kind of thing
especially when he means it right and so
but I wouldn't go in there
acting with be very careful not to use
any language that sounds like
entitlement okay you're not entitled to
anything you've been there for six
freaking months just out of college so
go in there humble but about just asking
how I can be so valuable that you can't
resist giving me money you know okay and
if you're leading that place wouldn't
you love to hear a guy say that I
wouldn't I would love you and so that
that's that's how switching the
moccasins helps you form your words
versus going in and going hey I'm one of
your two tech guys technical skill guys
with a four-year degree this place
wouldn't be happening without me and you
know you need a pony up buddy you know
and you know that's a complete different
attitude well and that one here and my
place will get you fired you have an
opposite effect yeah yeah yeah I think
part of it is like I struggle because
when I came to the job I was working in
emergency room where I was only making
maybe 20 grand a year yeah and so I knew
I had a baby coming on the way and so
the initial offer that they gave I
didn't even question I didn't ask for
anything different I said absolutely
sure jump you know right on board and
then you can you can bring that up
service you can bring that up and go man
I just I don't even ago she ate when you
came in I just took the job that's how
grateful I am and
and all I want to know is how I can help
you win at such a level and you can
point at me and go Niels the reason
we're winning at this level we're
writing Neil a cheque because we're in
it now you show me what to do and I'll
get about the business of doing that
because I want to be so valuable to this
place that you can't resist you know
paying me there's a great book out if
you want to pick it up that has that
kind of lingo and language in it called
linchpin by Seth Godin g.od I in and
you'll love that book and that's a great
question I love your attitude I love the
way you're approaching this you're
obviously a sharp young guy and you are
getting it done so you're the kind of
guy that deserves this it's just a
matter how we frame the discussion given
that we know the tables already set for
the discussion